nous sommes en zone militaire ces
amateurs de faune et de flore ont rendez
vous pour une visite exceptionnelle qui
n'a lieu qu'une fois par an une image de
ce qui était la bosse dans les années 50
avant le développement de la
mécanisation l'intensification des
pratiques agricoles
c'était exactement comme ça il est
intéressant de voir que les militaires
l'ont maintenu en l'état la base de
châteaudun et le premier site militaire
en région centre avoir signé une
convention pour préserver et développer
la biodiversité c'est la première fois
que je viens alors que j'ai travaillé
pendant douze ans sur la base sans être
consciente qu'il y avait une
biodiversité et des animaux
extraordinaires effectivement toute ma
carrière en faisant l'inspection de
piste je voyais des oiseaux joyet des
animaux mais sans y prêter attention
cette pelouse sèche recouvre 40% du site
on peut y observer les liant thème des
apennins une petite fleur aux pétales
blanche la pimprenelle ou encore cette
plante sans chlorophylle lors aux
branches parasites
mais le plus intéressant ne se voit pas
à l'oeil nu un oiseau extrêmement rare
en eure et loir
c'est le dit cnam criard et c'est vrai
que ça maso qui dépendent de ces milieux
ouverts secs rocailleux et on peut le
trouver sur ce sur ce site mais
malheureusement bon il est très farouche
c'est pour ça qu'on a des difficultés à
le voir mais aussi il se fait de plus en
plus rares il faut bien le dire
2h30 pour découvrir les richesses de
dame nature
le conservatoire des espaces naturels
centre val de loire propose de
nombreuses balades partout en région
centre